[موسيقى]
جمعيه القناص المصري في رعايه الجوارح هي
جمعيه مصريه وانشات 2018
هدفها هو نشر التراس السياره سيجاره او
السيجاره اللي هي
الصيد بالصور بالصور
هي تدريب الصقور للصيد بها كان زمان
بيعملوا كده عشان بيوفره احتياجاتهم من
اللحوم في في الاماكن في الصحراويه
البدو كانوا بيدربوا الصقور عشان يستظروهم
طيور
دلوقت هي بقت عباره عن تراث
وفي كثير قوي من الدول سواء كانت دول
اوروبا او دول الخليج جدا بقت اصبحت
الرياضه النهارده هي رياضه الصقور
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من اهم نشاطات الجمعيه عندنا هي رعايه
الجوارح وخصوصا الطيور اللي بتقع او تتمسك
في وقت الهجره وانت معي بالطيور والانواع
على تنفع على نشاطه في مصر والمخاطر اللي
بتتعرض لها والانواع اللي ما تنفعش اصلا
في اي مكان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]